c'est vrai que je vous parle beaucoup de
smartphones parce que celle objets
connectés que tout le monde a avec soin
mais également d'autres objets connectés
qu'on a beaucoup avec soi qu'on emmène
partout et tout un exploit c'est ça ce
sont les montres connectés d'ailleurs je
sais pas si vous en avez une dites le
moi tout de suite en bas en commentaire
dans l'univers des mondes connectés vous
ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois des montres
de mots boy l'attitude pragmatique wave
pro 2020 et là il ya un tout nouveau
modèle qui est extrêmement cool c'est la
petit couac pro 3 gps et cinq petits
couacs prend 3 gps est dur à prononcer
et bien gelée au poignet ici depuis
quelques jours et je la trouve vachement
intéressante parce que elle fait plein
de jolies promesses elle les tient
elle est plutôt cool je vais vous la
montrer de vous expliquer je vais tous
vous détailler et je voterai sans vous
bel évidemment pour dire ce que vous en
pensez en main en commentaire mais avant
toute chose si ce n'est pas déjà fait je
vous invite à venir vous abonner en
cliquant sur le petit bouton rouge que
vous avez juste là si les rochers vous
n'êtes toujours pas abonnés comme ça
vous le saurez tout de l'actuelle smart
phones montre ordinateur pc que je parle
surtout de vous de vos usages de votre
vie numérique qu'est ce que vous faites
devient qu'est ce qui est bien qu'à ce
qu'ils les paras sont labellisés genre
toujours ce marais ensemble voilà
j'habite à quitter son petit bouton
rouge en dessous comme ça vous saurez
tout si vous vous intéressez à l'univers
des montres peut-être connaissez-vous
les montres de mode veille
personnellement j'en ai déjà porté
quelques unes pendant un bon petit
moment et je dois reconnaître qu'à
chaque fois et bien beaubreuil me
surprend ils progressent ils vont
toujours plus loin et là avec cette
tique watch pro 3 gps et bien je dois
dire quand même qu'ils ont fait c'est
fort je monte sans détails le but est
l'adn de cette montre c'est d'avoir deux
écrans superposés le premier vous le
voyez la garde et vous voyez leur vous
voyez là d'adp voyez le nombre de pas
vous avez le niveau de la batterie
restante et vous avez les secondes là ça
c'est un écran lcd mais en dessous vous
avez un écran amoled en couleurs un
écran de 1,4 pouces avec une résolution
de 454 par 454 le principe de la montre
est très cool vous avez ces deux écrans
lorsque vous ne l'utilisez pas que vous
l'avez au poignet juste pour avoir les
informations essentielles d'où l'idée
d'essentiel mode c'est le nom du mode et
bien vous avez leur qui s'affiche sur
votre écran lcd qui ne consomme
quasiment rien en batterie tandis que
lorsque vous voulez l'utiliser votre
montre et naviguer
ailleurs comme sur n'importe quel monde
connecté bien vous allez utiliser
l'écran amoled qu'il y a en dessous et
là par contre elle doit consommer
davantage donc l'idée cette
configuration c'est de jouer sur
l'autonomie pour vous ayez une montre
que vous puissiez emmener le plus loin
possible sans avoir besoin de la changer
au delà de ça on a un design qui est
vraiment bien réussi sur tourner le
monde qui est plus fine que la
génération précédente génération
précédente de cette année on parle bien
de l'attique watch prod 2020 on a un
bracelet en silicone qui a des faux airs
de bracelet en cuir plutôt bien vous
pouvez donc utiliser pour le sport et ça
c'est vraiment très très cool on
retrouve deux boutons sur le côté un
premier bouton qui vous permettra
d'accéder à votre menu très facilement
ou de revenir en arrière et un deuxième
bouton qui vous servira à appeler le
mode sport pour venir faire du sport
comme vous le souhaitez vous avez plein
plein de mode il faut savoir qu'ici vous
tournez sur wiiware os c'est un très
grand standard vous voulez s'est appuyé
pour changer de quadrant et vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités ça
c'est vraiment très très cool vous
balayer comme ça vous avez accès à vos
différents paramètres le mode avion
google paye pour activer retrouver vos
smartphones et compagnie sur le bas vous
avez accès à vos notifications et ça
c'est aussi très très cool sur la partie
de droite vous avez des widgets avec
notamment votre parti sport est ce que
vous avez fait aujourd'hui autant vous
dire que j'ai pas été très efficace
aujourd'hui la météo
votre calendrier un peu d'actu parce que
sur la partie de gauche eh bien vous
avez effectivement un bout de météo avec
votre google assistant est en dessous
vous avez des notifications comme on est
sur google ou air sur ouais c'est bien
vous avez un catalogue d'applications et
ça c'est vachement cool le plextor dans
lequel faisait pouvoir venir télécharger
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de logiciels
notamment du google maps les messages
tout ce que vous voulez c'est très cool
et ça marche bien messenger spotify
shazam télégramme outlook et je vous en
passe et des meilleurs autre mise à jour
qui est importante c'est au niveau de la
puce on est passé sur la dernière plus
de qualcomm pour les montres connectés
c'est le snapdragon 4100 sur la tique
auch pro 2020 ont lutté sur la
génération précédente c'était là 3100
ici on va voir plus de performances et
on aura également une meilleure gestion
de l'énergie ce qui vous donne un écart
de 25% entre la génération précédente
d'il ya quelques mois on va retrouver un
giga de ram 8 gigas de stockage pouvoir
stocker vos différentes applications
directement en interne on a une batterie
qui est plus grosse 577 millions terreur
contre 415 millions terreur pour la
génération précédente vous avez donc une
puce qui va mieux gérer l'énergie
vous avez une plus grosse capacité de
stockage vous avez donc une autonomie
qui est accrue ou vous allez pouvoir
aller jusqu'à 72 heures
mode smart et 45 jours en mode
essentielle alors le mode essentielles
vous allez pas restés 45 jours sur le
mode est essentielle si vous voulez
déclencher le mode essentielles pures
vous pouvez le faire d'ailleurs ce que
vous n'avez plus beaucoup de batterie
vous pouvez déclencher le mode essentiel
ce qui fait vous aurez l'heure et c'est
bien a minima mais vous ne pourrez pas
l'utiliser comme une montre intelligente
et un monde connecté mais en tout cas
elle continuera à faire le job
quant à son utilisation de mots tout
simples de la même manière plus vous
allez rajouter d'options et plus vous
allez venir consommer davantage donc
l'autonomie va pouvoir fluctuer en
fonction de ce que vous allez en faire
de vos usages des options vous allez
active et notamment au niveau du suivi
de santé et ça je le monde en quelques
instants
en plus de ça vous avez le gps avec gail
lots vous avez bay dont nous allons
pouvoir l'utiliser en mode gps un peu
partout dans le monde pour faire du
sport donc ça c'est aussi cool
elle pèse à peine 41 g très légère le
bracelet se ferment bien écouter
innovation n'a pas moins de douze l'aide
que vous allez avoir répartis tout au
tout quatre petits ce lot de trois
lettres chacun 12 l'aide en tout plus de
l'infrarouge mais les nouveautés se
situent au niveau des applications vous
avez notamment tic oxygène qui vous
permettra de calculer votre niveau de
saturation en oxygène dans votre sens
grâce justement à ces nouveaux capteurs
donc la voyez une saturation 95 % ce qui
est normal peut avoir différents relevés
dans la journée je les enregistre dans
la semaine pour voir où j'en suis a bon
c'est le début de la semaine lis pas
beaucoup d'informations il voyait je
peux venir paramétrer et notamment de
faire une surveillance sur 24 heures
alors ça c'est plutôt intéressant si
vous voulez vraiment savoir où vous êtes
et si vous avez des besoins en termes de
santé ça va venir consommer davantage de
batterie mais si vous en avez besoin et
bien vous pouvez faire autre nouveauté
vous avez tic zen qui vous permettra de
vous détendre de vous relâcher et de
voir où est ce que vous en êtes au
niveau de votre stress là on me demande
de rester immobile pendant une minute
pour dire mesurer mon au stress autant
dire tout de suite c'est pas la peine je
suis bien speed je peux choisir le temps
une minute plus pour revenir vraiment me
relâcher prendre soin de moi donc ça
c'est vraiment cool et de la même
manière et bien ensuite voyez je peux
avoir des informations dans la journée
où j'étais le plus bas le plus élevé
j'en ai fait qu'une aujourd'hui
donc j'étais plutôt bien au niveau du
score à 10 j'ai ensuite toutes les
informations distribution de pression
j'étais détendu à 100% parce que j'étais
pas trop trop stressé au moment où j'ai
fait le test mais si je le faisais
maintenant je pense que c'est quand même
un peu plus dans le haut-anjou voire
carrément dans le rouge
et de la même manière j'ai mes
informations sur la semaine pas de
nouveauté c'est sympathique kering ça va
venir vraiment mesurer le sont autour de
moi pour savoir s'il faut que je parte
ou pas alors là je parle très fort à
côté de la montre si j'arrête de faire
du bruit
eh bien voyez tout ça redescend à 50
décibels à la les gens meurent parlé un
petit peu forte hausse 8,5 à terre ça
dépend effectivement de la proximité de
la montre
rapport à la source la source et moi je
parle je fais du bruit à côté donc
forcément c'est très très fort mais
imaginez vous êtes dans une salle de
spectacle nous permettra de savoir s'il
faut fuir ou pas alors pour l'instant je
sais que ça le spectacle c'est compliqué
mais ça va bien finir par revenir autre
nouveauté ces types bresse où vous allez
pouvoir venir respirer pendant une
minute
bon ça fait un peu doublon avec l
application que je vous montre tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas si vous voulez
me relâcher et respire et bien vous
pouvez le faire vous avez de
l'application de santé les exercices
pour faire du sport parce que bien
évidemment pas le demande colleter donc
on parle de sport course en extérieur en
marchant l'extérieur course en intérieur
du vélo cyclisme en salle freestyle
nager dans la piscine nager y manque
l'obtiennent nager dans la piscine
rameurs machines elliptiques aérobie
dutreil de la montée du week-end pas mal
de possibilités et ça c'est très très
cool on a toujours tip ou pour savoir où
on en est un instant t d'ailleurs fait
voir quand je fais des vidéos c'est
plutôt rare que je sois calme conso de
grès ocre et voyez c'est pas mal donc
voyez ensuite j'ai mon petit reporting
et de la même manière je vois que j'ai
tapé le plus doucement et le plus
rapidement aujourd'hui j'ai une vision
un petit peu sur échauffement repos
qu'on saute grèce et de la même manière
je pourrais savoir s'il ya une anomalie
ou pas pour venir surveiller ma
fréquence cardiaque et je tenir ici
activer le suivi 24 heures donc ça je
vous le conseille vraiment si vous avez
des problèmes cardiaques pour avoir un
vrai suivi vous mettez les données à
surveiller limite inférieure limite
supérieure et ça viendra vous prévenir
lorsque vous avez dépassé ces limites
soit en dessous de 40 battements par
minute soit au dessus de 120 battements
par minute vous avez également une
analyse et suivi de sommeil alors moi je
suis pas un bon client pour sa maman ne
l'utilisent pas pour le sommeil donc je
vais pas vous donner de retour là dessus
mais si vous voulez analyser votre cycle
de sommeil et bien vous pouvez le faire
la larme le chronomètre le moniteur la
météo les contacts le mode essentiel
qu'ils pouvaient venir activé
directement ici si vous le souhaitez la
lampe de poche et toutes vos
applications de sports liés à auvers os
de google exercice une suite respiration
fréquence cardiaque les messages de
google mont pelé store minuteur de
lavage de mains ça c'est vachement bien
ça vous dirai combien de temps il faut
vous laver les mains vous mettez du
savon et hop vous êtes parti pour 40
secondes pour avoir les mains très très
propre et on file vous et vos
différentes applications pouvait venir
télécharger et utiliser directement ici
même si les montants collectés sont
suffisamment avancés en termes de
technologie pour avoir des informations
fiables sur votre rythme cardiaque sur
votre saturation ça ne remplacera jamais
des appareils médicaux consultez votre
médecin en attendant le petit monitoring
vous pouvez avoir là dessus
eh bien ça vous permet de savoir où vous
en êtes à un instant t as vu
vraiment vous surveillez vous monitorer
pour les personnes qui ont des besoins
de santé c'est très cool donc on voit
qu'on est une montre qui s'adresse aussi
bien aux personnes qui ont des besoins
de santé avec de la consommation
immédiate notamment au niveau cardiaque
au niveau de la saturation du sang on va
pas aussi loin que ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver chez apple au niveau 2 le cg
haut niveau toutes ces fonctionnalités
là on a néanmoins une montre qui est
très cool un design qui est plus fin une
montre avec une excellente autonomie et
c'est vraiment tout l'adn de l'attique
watch pro avec ses deux écrans avec le
mode essentiel donc ça c'est très cool
et très bien réussi de la part mode
veille
le fait que vous aviez ouvert web de
google derrière c'est génial vous avez
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé
vous avez une honte qui est certifié
résistante à l'eau et à la poussière
avec une certification ip68 vous pouvez
aller nager à la piscine avec avec ce
bracelet qui a un côté un peu caujolle
lifestyle avec une ressemblance cuir
mais qui pourtant est bel et bien du
silicone donc si vous voulez nager avec
cette montre telle qu'elle est là et
bien vous pouvez le faire
moi je trouve très cool très cool au
niveau de l'autonomie très cool au
niveau des services très cool au niveau
de ce que propose mauvais oeil dessus
toutes les nouveautés tic et c'est une
honte qui est disponible au tarif de 299
euros 99 qui est plutôt bien positionné
si vous voulez une belle montre avec
webos est bien celle là elle est
vraiment intéressante à vous de me dire
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter par cette
tique watch pro 3 gps ou gps mais on
connaît de façon indépendante pour aller
faire du sport sans problème dites moi
tout ça en bas en commentaire talon se
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler takes to win la taxe
ne s'arrête pas il ya plein de choses de
tous les côtés on parlera de montre
beaucoup de smartphones et je prépare
aussi beaucoup beaucoup et beaucoup de
belles surprises pour les temps à venir
sur ce prenez soin de vous je vous
embrasse m'ont beaucoup d'amour et à
très vite
ciao
[Musique]
oh